the rationale that is given for these
types of law these laws tends to be not
necessarily that teenagers should never
see a naked woman or something like that
but that there's something specifically
wrong with online porn the sheer
quantity and volume of it the lawmaker
be the the lawmaker behind Louisiana's
age verification ban which is the one
that really got the ball rolling on this
uh to make online porn less accessible
apparently was motivated by an interview
that she heard with Billy eish the
popular singer that she gave to Howard
Stern in 20121 about her personal
experiences with online pornography I'd
like to roll that clip and get aa's
reaction to what she's saying about the
effects that she thinks porn had on
her as a woman I think porn is a
disgrace and I used to
watch a lot of porn to be honest I
started watching porn when I was like 11
I thought that's how you learned how to
have sex I was watching um abusive porn
to be honest you know when I was like 14
and I you know thought I was one of the
guys and would talk about it and think
it was really cool for for for not
having a problem with it and not seeing
why it was bad and I think it really
destroyed my brain and um I feel
incredibly
devastated that I was exposed to so much
porn I think that I had like sleep
paralysis and these like almost like
night terror SL just nightmares because
of it I think that's how they started
because I would just watch abusive BDSM
I couldn't watch anything else like
unless it was violent I like didn't
think it was attractive and I had was a
virgin I I had never done anything and
and so I I let it it led to problems
where you know the first the first few
times I you know had sex I was not
saying no to things that
were not good and it's because I thought
that that's what I was supposed to be
attracted to and I just I am I'm so
angry that porn is
so loved and it's how so many people
think that they're supposed to learn
it's how so many men think that they're
supposed to be and because in porn
there's no
consent uh like getting thrown around
during sex if you're not interested in
being slapped and being choked people
are like you're vanilla you're soft
you're that's not you're boring in bed
and I'm not talking about me I'm talking
about women women are like oh I have to
like being hurt to be thought of as good
and
bad what do you think about the
experiences she's recounting there that
porn just it work s your expectations to
of what sexuality could and should
be I'm like slightly confused by her
accounting like why where did she get
the idea that being hurt like the Abus
of porn was the cool porn like was she
around a bunch of other like preens
being like hey did you watch this
violent BDSM like I I've I I I just I'm
legitimately confused like maybe it's
possible that there's whole C out there
like when I first when she first started
talking about I'm like oh she's just
into it and then like hasn't come to
terms with the fact that she's kinky but
then she said she didn't actually find
it attractive so I'm like why are you it
it takes quite a lot of like cultural um
force in some way to like make people
regularly watch porn that they're not
aroused by like have you ever tried
watching porn you're not aroused by like
ever right right how have you done that
right like so this is I'm just confused
again I'm not saying that like that
she's like incorrect or something I'm
just I noticed that something's not
adding up here um yeah I mean I know you
have written about the about violent
porn and you know she the way the way
she's laying it out there is the is it's
like it makes men want to engage in
really rough violent sex and then women
feel like they have to like that too
you're you're writing on this uh and
your your research seems to show that
it's actually women who have a
preference for more violent pornography
could you talk a little bit about that
yeah absolutely I mean like like to to
pump our intuition here you look at
Women's romance novels um there's a lot
of like pretty aggressive men who are
not that interested in consent uh and
this is like written by women for women
um the 50 Shades of Gray most popular
selling women's novel uh and I don't
think that it's because women are
desperately trying to please men so that
they go and make this novel so popular
that like most men don't give a [__]
about um and basically every yeah like
that the the thing that you pulled up um
I I did a survey where I asked people
partially my audience and partially
people I paid who are random have no
association with me um and I asked like
men what to predict what they thought
that women would like in bed like hey
let's say you try oh wait actually oh
this might be a different I forget I
wrote a couple different blogs so I get
them mixed up but I've got a couple of
your graphs here that maybe we could
talk about that will be a way to talk
about it that this is the one where you
asked how often do you read or watch
erotic content for the purposes of
arousal and it shows that overall
unsurprisingly CIS men watch and read
more erotic content than women but then
you ask how much of the porn you watch
is
violent um CIS men they're
uh you know over 30% said none for women
that number is lower 25% so it's the you
know the absolute number of men watching
porn unsurprisingly is higher but of the
women who do watch porn they are more
likely than men to watch violent porn
and like the theory where it's like oh a
pressure from men is causing women to
want like maybe you could be like oh
women are reporting that they like
violent porn because they're trying to
please men but like let's say we're in a
world where we have like say 40% of men
really like violent porn and like in in
truth only 10% of women do and then we
have a bunch of cultural pressure from
the men like oh more women should like
violent porn um I wouldn't expect the
number of women that like violent porn
to get shot up that that degree like I
maybe I would see some inflation like oh
now it's like 15% or 20% of women are
reporting it but like the fact that now
more women than men are reporting
interest in violent porn like that just
doesn't seem to be really consistent
with this Theory
yeah I I want to get a little bit a few
more of your your findings on human
sexuality because that that you know you
you have these huge samples like how do
you remember off top of your head about
how big that uh your your survey was
where you're drawing this data from it's
still coming in U now it's 622,000
cleaned okay but more than that
uncleaned depending on how you clean it
yeah yeah so I mean that that's a huge
sample and I was looking through some of
it some of your results in preparing for
this one was this uh what women say they
like versus what men predict women will
like because it's you know the the idea
that Billy Alish is putting forth in
that clip is that porn sort of warps
men's Brains to make them think women
want different things than they actually
want uh but if you look here I mean it's
like the the the the most popular answer
on both sides you know like call her
beautiful and sexy kissing conolingus
missionary with legs up like it's
matching almost it's not a perfect match
but it's it's pretty close um I mean was
that were those kind of results at all
surprising to you or what it what do you
make from that data I mean the fact that
they're close isn't like overall close
is not that surprising I try to have
like a broad spectrum from like extreme
vanilla and like everybody likes it to
like extremely bad like very few people
would like it so like the lowest one
here is like uh like tell her she's ug
call her ugly or like shove her head in
a
toilet both sexes agree that that's not
not rims you that's another one that is
just you know not quite catching on just
yet
yeah um but but so yeah there's there
doesn't seem to be there don't seem to
be a lot of men and answering that you
know you should that they think shoving
a woman's head in a toilet or like
pissing on her face is the I actually
asked that one because once the guy
shoved my head into a toilet and I was
like
huh wow it was
interesting I don't think it's thing but
like I'm glad to have experienced
it I mean the water or like how far in
did your head no very close to the water
I thought that I thought he was GNA
my would that changed your appreciation
of it of the experience I don't think so
I think I mean I I would prefer not
having my head shied in any more toilets
yeah but I like it's just I don't know
it's like interesting to go through that
experience because like yeah when do you
ever get the opportunity to have your
head shift in a toilet very infrequently
in my daily life unfortunately
apparently sorry I'm a journalist so I
have to ask the important follow-up
questions like thanks for thanks for
digging into that one uh you know it's
like a a problem that we run into
often in 2023 America is like anytime
there's a potential downside or harm to
some product whether that's porn or
drugs there's like almost an assumption
that therefore State prohibition or at
least regulation is the remedy and I
think all of us in this conversation
reject that notion none of us are for
Banning porn even if some of us think
kids shouldn't have you know unmitigated
access to it or that porn might be bad
for some people I think though that if
we want to move towards a Freer Society
where we leave more responsibility with
individuals to moderate themselves
instead of relying on the state to Nanny
us it's going to require honest
discussion about downsides or pitfalls
we don't have to like something or
celebrate everything to tolerate it and
I just want to give that preface before
we talk about a little bit more about
some of the major criticisms of the
online porn industry um many of which
were raised in this article for skeptic
magazine called how porn is messing with
your manhood which was authored by three
writers who've written full books on
what they see as the The Scourge or the
downsize of online porn and I just want
to bring up a couple of these with you
ala because there criticisms you hear
commonly and I want to know if you think
there's much to them um and if so if
there's anything that can be done
realistically to mitigate this other
than trying to implement a porn band
that certainly won't work um one of this
uh one of these ideas is what the author
calls sexual anorexia and he bases a lot
of this argument off an Italian uh
survey that found that um you know by
sexual anorexia he means difficulty
having sex with a real partner so the
researcher Professor Carlo Forest uh
explained that the problem worsens when
young men's sexuality develops
independently from real life sexual
relationships he said viewers who
watched a lot of porn especially if they
started early 14 years old um became
less responsive first to the porn itself
and then their libido dropped and
finally it becomes difficult to get an
erection and there is some you know
wider empirical data showing the rise of
uh erectile dysfunction among younger
men worldwide and in in America as well
we can't directly link that to porn but
it's a
phenomenon um but what do you is that
something you've observed or have any uh
anything to say about the the idea that
that men can become reliant on porn for
sexual release and then don't know what
to do in a real life situation with a
woman yeah there's some some like a
professor friends I have that say that
like sex porn addiction isn't a real
thing um and I am not sure that I find
that convincing you just need to find
like one person who like a good
introspection who reports like hey I
feel like this is damaging my life and
you can get addicted to so many things
it just feels weird to be like you can't
just to put like a pin in one end of it
but on the other hand it's like
difficult for me to under to like trust
a lot of the research on this because
it's so motivated in both directions
people are really personally offended by
pornography and there's also um there's
a lot of uh incentive for self-insight
to go Ary here like um like if you are
say for example having erectile
dysfunction problems for other reasons
like that might be Health rated um it
might be very easy for you to try to
find a causal thing that that you're
aware of like oh maybe it's the porn
that's doing it we see this with
fetishes all the time a lot of my data
doesn't support the childhood
experiences correlate with fetishes and
yet we constantly have narratives like
oh I think I'm into this thing because
you know I was spanked as a child or I
wasn't spanked as a child or something
um so I just am like very up at close
and personal all the time to the way
that we can like make stories connect
with our lives in ways that turn out to
be completely fake um yeah and I'm not
saying that they're always fake I'm just
saying that like when I'm reading people
making like causal claims about this
it's just something you have to be super
super careful about we have to really I
have to pick through the study um and
like tried looking at different
questions to try and coordinate like
triangulate what the answer might be um
I think a lot of the discussion around
porn addiction um is misguided for this
reason I I would would be surprised if
it were all true but again I would be
surprised if none of it were true I so
my guess is that PR addiction is like a
legitimate problem where it is [__]
some people up my guess a smaller number
of people than a lot of this discourse
currently is claiming yeah on on the
issue of fetishes that was another topic
that they raised in this article that
because on these porn sites you can
effortlessly click from scene to scene
and genre and genre to genre to boost
your rousel it's like you've put
yourself in a Skinner box like the
change means that you can just condition
they say condition your arousal patterns
to an ongoing escalating and
everchanging Novelty so thus users are
conditioning their sexual arousal
template to everything associated with
their porn use their brains then expect
these things during sexual arousal yet
none of these attributes of online porn
match sex with the real person who
cannot compete with the buffet provided
by by a porn so the argument boils down
to it's giving you porn brain um you get
sucked down these very specific fetish
rabbit holes um is there anything to
that uh have you observed that either in
your survey data or you know dealing
with real life clients this is the thing
I'm much more sus about like the other
things like maybe porn R maybe but this
I'm like just it feels so much more
skeptical like uh in my theory currently
which take go the great Sal I may come
back and be like actually I've updated
this Bas on our data but currently my
theory is that there's like kind of two
categories of uh like ways that you can
have a fetish and one is that it has
early onset and it is quite strong so
like you typically people in this
category remember their fetishes
happening like some of their earliest
memories just like an intense
fascination with this thing and now this
thing as an adult is quite Central to
their sexuality and then secondarily you
have a l late onset and this is due to
some kind of conditioning and it's
usually much milder so this is kind of
like guy whose girlfriend puts her hair
up in a ponytail every time she gives
him a blue job and now he's out and like
sees a girl put her hair in a ponytail
at a grocery store and he like gets a
chub like that's what I would consider
to be like conditioned sexuality um and
but usually they're not uh like fetishes
in the classic sense that we think of
that term like they're not super strong
um but you I think the way most
fetishistic sexuality works is very
similar to sexual orientation some
people uh like latch on to feet some
people latch on to like being gay
honestly I think latching on to being
straight is like the default one I don't
think that these are meaningfully
different um but uh and we know how well
gay conversion camps work we know what
happens when we try extremely hard to
recondition people's sexuality um in the
terms of orientation uh it's basically
incredibly ineffective and so like this
is why I have quite a bit of Doubt when
it comes to reconditioning like deep
sexuality uh in other regards like if
you you can't make somebody attracted
from penises to vaginas like you're not
going to be able to make somebody become
that level of attracted to like feet or
bondage or something you can do like the
conditioning thing like your girlfriend
puts her hair up in a ponytail but
there's no way you can change a fetish
on the level of like this happened early
and it is deeply Central to my sexuality
no way hey thanks for watching that clip
from our conversation with Aya about
porn laws the sexual Revolution and the
freedom to browse the internet privately
and speak anonymously you can watch
another clip right here or the full
conversation over here